- [Voiceover] This episode
of CC: Social Scene
is based on your suggestions
for weird family members.
- Summertime means
family reunions.
They were fun when you were
a kid but now you're older
and they just don't
have the same magic.
- Can I just not go?
- No, it'll break
your mother's heart.
But don't worry because I'm here
to give you tips
on how to survive
your summer family reunion.
Step one, breathe.
Take it all in.
This is your family.
You share the same
genes with these people.
Some are older, collecting dust.
And some are young, collecting
nine volt batteries.
Like it or not, you're
connected to them.
Step two, hug your mother.
Do this immediately.
The sooner you hug your
mother and let her tell
an embarrassing
story about you--
- He used to pee
his pants every day.
(laughs)
- The sooner you can leave.
Step three, free food.
Make your way to
that food but beware.
There are obstacles
you have to avoid.
Like your cousin Kibbers.
- Hey Doug!
I was hoping I'd see you here.
Have I told you
about Gift Buddies?
- I don't know.
- You don't know
what Gift Buddies is
but you know one thing,
it's a pyramid scheme.
- It's not a pyramid
scheme, it's just gifts
for your buddies.
I'll email you about it.
- Sounds legit.
- [Voiceover] Woah,
woah, woah, woah, woah.
Who's that?
- Hey, Doug.
- Hi.
Do we know each other?
- Doug, you remember
your cousin June?
- Oh yeah.
- [Voiceover] Get out of there.
It's food time.
- Dude, V.R. goggles.
- It's Uncle Rick.
He's a self-proclaimed tech head
and undying conspiracy theorist.
- It's a fake world,
like the moon landing.
- [Doug] Okay.
- T-T-Y-L.
Oh, chem trails.
- It's just a cloud.
(regal music)
- You made it.
Now enjoy that burger
with some chips and beer.
You earned this.
And now it's time
for the final step.
Leave.
- Really?
- Yeah, you did the
whole thing, right?
You hugged your mother.
Now it's time to go before
she tells that story
about how you ate a urinal cake.
- It was one time.
- Yeah, find the
quickest route and go.
(dramatic music)
- Get me out of here.
- And that's how you survive
a summer family barbecue.
Good luck out there.
And don't drop your grandmas.
- Hey, I fixed the
satellite dish.
(screams)
I'm okay.
- So, want to get out of here?
After you, my lady.
- [Voiceover] Join
the conversation now
with CCSocialScene.
Tell us about your worst
vacation rental experience
and we might write it
in to our next sketch.
Presented by Redd's Apple
Ale, pick different.